Donald Trump has been filling convention
centers parks and aircraft hangars for
months now his rallies are like rock
concerts with his adoring fans desperate
to hear their favorite riffs I will
build a wall don't even think about it
if Hillary Clinton is public enemy
number one here the media is a very
close second from his podium Trump has
been fueling resentment for journalists
they're just bad people the media they
are bad people they're among the most
dishonest people I've ever met in my
life
total phonies they're bad people they're
bad people
this is one of the crowds favorite
moments at a trump rally it's almost
like cancer mine
Trump is the hero we're the villains and
his message is resonating
the merchandise outside a rally is a big
part of the show this sign pretty much
sums up the sentiment Donald Trump is a
warrior bravely withstanding the
mainstream media's efforts to bring him
down arguably it's a smart tactic
everything unflattering becomes a lie
are you guys part of the crooked media
the crooked media
well the crooked media is a liberal
media that portrays Trump as you know a
bad person and makes Hillary look like
she's an angel the media in general been
reporting only about Hillary Clinton's
emails lately surely it's been pretty
valid but it's a lot of stuff they're
keeping keeping out from from the
general public not hearing negative
things about Donald Trump d well that's
true but it's it's what I mean why
shouldn't we report negative things
about Donald Trump he's saying there are
none
well no it's no negative things about
your own there's no negative thing
though so anyone that reports that
controversial but it's not I mean from
my point of view nothing's negative oh
good he's all good in my books and I
think you know the media you guys are
that you guys are the ones that are the
crooked ones with Hillary so I got to
end it I don't like crooked media you
gotta go the hostility isn't just
reserved for the media
this family came to disrupt Trump's
rally because 12 year-old Joseph who's
in the wheelchair was angry at Trump's
mockery of a disabled reporter what
happened what happened then they start
pushing on his wheelchair and hostile
somebody kicked me a women but Donald
Trump's supporters are buying any of
this
Trump knows exactly how to please his
crowd he's relying on them to get him
into the white whatever happens the
angurius own won't evaporate and
remember the man Amanda Walker Sky News
Tampa Florida